[Music]
hello friends we are so excited that we
can be with you again in our program i'd
like to know
and i have a very special friend with me
here pastor c.a murray as always and
i've learned a lot from you in this
program ca so for me it is a pleasure to
be here with you good to be here with
you daniel and we're so happy that
you're also
sharing with us in this program
and as ca often says we will try to
answer to you these questions from the
word of god
feel free to participate sending your
questions at tv
at some tv.org again this is tv at some
tv.org
we will be very happy to answer your
questions
so just have some patience we will get
there
we have uh still a bunch of questions to
answer but we promise
that we will answer
your question
we have uh very
good questions for today as always
but we don't want to begin before
praying god for wisdom so i like to ask
see if you can pray for us as we open
gracious father we praise you and thank
you for the privilege that is ours to
study your word
we thank you that your word is indeed a
lamp unto our feet
and a light on the pathway before us and
we thank you that your word can be
studied and that it can be put
into our lives and into practice so that
we are made better amen your servant
ellen white said that we need to pray
for wisdom to know what you want us to
do and then for power to put into
practice that which we know to be right
so give us this day wisdom and power yes
as we seek to serve you and unpackage
the truths that are hidden in your word
we love you we thank you
in jesus name amen amen
amen
well our first question for today
comes from darlene newman
and she has a question in regards to the
seven last plagues i'll try to summarize
the question
um
the question goes like this how can we
be consistent in our methodology
when interpreting the seven last plagues
when we use symbols and symbolic
language in the rest of the book of
revelation
but it appears that we
literalize
all of the plagues except the river
euphrates
this blends my mind a bit and violates
consistency
so wouldn't wouldn't it be best to use
symbolic interpretation of
all the plagues not just
one
thank you as always and god's blessing
good question a good question
sadly though it makes a couple errors in
in her looking at the river euphrates so
let's go
to where it is mentioned and that is
revelation chapter 16. very good and
verse 12
and i'll read it
make a couple statements and i know
you've studied this also uh daniel so
we'll uh we'll sort of blend our
thoughts here
revelation 16 12
then the sixth angel poured out his bowl
on the great river euphrates and its
water was dried up so that the way of
the kings from the east
might be prepared
we can stop there
and that's verse 12 of chapter 16.
she says that
we
literalize this particular
statement this particular sentence
but the truth is
we are consistent
one of the
biblical rules for
hermeneutics is that
you
take the bible literally until it shows
that
it is
dealing with things that ought to
represent other things and so your
exegesis has to take that into account
we're using terms here hermeneutics are
the rules you use for
interpreting what the bible says and
exegesis i think we can boil down to
basically the process
of interpreting
so the rules you use for a particular
process that you develop so you take the
bible at its word literally unless it is
showing you
that this context is otherwise and
should be done um
uh prophetically or uh in a way that
says that there are many explanations to
what you're discussing
and it is so with the great river
euphrates there are literal
explanations but there is also a
spiritual prophetic interpretation also
so we are being consistent now literally
the river euphrates was uh
the river that protected that uh water
that went through babylon
and uh so it's an actual river
the river was dried up we know when
bermuda persians came in to conquer the
babylonians uh and they went through
under the gates and we know about that
story
spiritually
we've got very strong parallels
so maybe we ought to start with with
babylon right
what is babylon
we find babylon in the book of
revelation as a spurious
uh political religious system that
is an enemy of god's people and god
himself
um we see babylon in revelation 17 for
example represented as a woman a harlot
that is riding on a beast
that has also daughters who are harlots
so in a nutshell babylon is a false
religious system
of yeah
yeah that's about as clean as we can
make it and quickly it's a false
religious system now of course we we
know that
uh
women equal churches in revelation
and so babylon is an a a profligate
woman a harlot so it's a it's a woman or
a church system that has not been true
to god
she has daughters
um
she has those who believe like uh she
does we are told going back uh to
revelation 14 and the three and those
messages that we need to come out of
babylon so it means that we as god's
people need to separate ourselves from
those religious systems that are not
true to god that are spurious to god
so
um we understand that babylon is going
to
go through some things in the last time
in the last days and the river euphrates
drying up
has to do with the support the
protection
that babylon has been afforded all of
these years
um
you have something to add to that yes uh
as it was with literal babylon little
babylon was sitting on the river
euphrates
spiritual babylon is also sitting on
spiritual waters and the spiritual
waters are multitudes nations tongues
and people and people
we read that in revelation 17
verse
15 the what the waters represent so
there is a spiritual
river euphrates
this time that spiritual river euphrates
is uh
the support of the
support from the politicians everyone in
the world those who would follow the
beast and will give the support to the
beast
these represent
the waters now the question that
our dear sister asked has to do with the
consistency
in using symbolic
language
there is a
a book that i read
some years ago
a very good book
by louise where an old good book oh yes
the certainty of the three angels
messages
and in that book he explains and he he
brings up a hermeneutical principle of
bible interpretation prophetic
interpretation
when it comes to babylon
whatever is said in regards to spiritual
babylon
in revelation should be symbolic because
babylon is symbolic
the first four plagues do not fall
directly on babylon but the last three
do that's why the last three
are often we often interpret them as
symbolic for example the fifth plague
darkness upon the throne of the beast we
understand that that's not only darkness
on rome
but there will be a
darkness around the world
and
we see
in in the seventh plague
we see some literal aspects but also
some symbolic aspects like the city
broken up in three parts
that refers also to the final overthrow
of babylon but as as you said ca
unless
the context it gives us something else
we should interpret the bible
literally depending on the context and
and these plagues are real
uh the scourges that we read
in the first four plagues
those are real
plagues actually ellen y understood them
like that yes
yes so
in trying to
to keep this in a fairly
neat package
babylon the the what's going to happen
to spiritual babylon is real
the waters are going to be dried up now
if you continue to read and 17 does a
nice job of walking you through some of
the questions that are posed in chapter
16 of revelation
and the ten horns which you saw on the
beast
these will hate the harlot and make her
desolate and naked eat her flesh and
burn her with fire so
if we say that
the
river euphrates was the support that
spiritual babylon received then the
drying up of the river fragrance is
what's happening here we just read it is
that these
entities that have been duped
will understand
that
babylon has been lying to them and the
drying up means they will withdraw their
support they no longer support her they
no longer are in league with her so the
the meaning is very much spiritual and
we are being consistent in our
exegesis of this particular text and of
of the river euphrates
yep
let me read
real quick from the great controversy
pages 627
and
28. ellen y is describing here the first
four plagues
and
she says
when christ seizes his intercession
in the sanctuary the unmingled wrath
threatened against those who worship the
beast and his image and receive his mark
will be poured out the plagues upon
egypt when god was about to deliver
israel were similar in character to
those more terrible and extensive
judgments we are
which are to fall upon the world just
before the final deliverance of god's
people and we know that the plagues in
egypt were literally
um says the revelator in describing
those terrific scourges
and then she quotes revelation 16
through 2 through 6
and then she says
by condemning the people of god to death
they have as truly incurred the guilt of
their blood as if it had been shed by
their hands in like manner
christ declared
the jews of his time guilty of all the
blood of holy men which had been
since the days of abel and next
paragraph one more point in the plague
that follows
a power is given to the sun to scorch
men with fire and men were scorched with
great
heat
so
we don't see any illusion any symbolic
illusion from ellen white when she
explains the first four
plagues and then she says these plagues
are not universal or the inhabitants of
the earth
would be wholly cut off so the first
four
are not universal
so because the the inhabitants of the
world would be cut off that means that
the scourges are literal because they
kill people yes
yes yes yes so
this this is an excellent question
but um
we
well she's saying literally spiritualize
um
we we we see that the river euphrates
has great prophetic significance right
as we make our way to the
end of this earth's history and um
so
the context drives our our understanding
of babylon and the contract context
drives our understanding of the uh river
euphrates thank you darlene it's a great
question but i think we are consistent
in our understanding of babylon the
waters on which she sits the support
that she receives and how that support
will one day be dried up and we'll be no
more thank you great great question
okay we have another question from
i don't want to do violence the name
katuka i think that's how it is
pronounced
she says greetings pastor boar
i would like to find
to find out from you how to perform
christian meditation god bless
you know the first thing that comes to
my mind i've got several quotes here
that say that we
uh
ought to meditate
but there is good meditation and there
is bad meditation correct all right so
i'm going to take something very quickly
from desire vegas page 207
the demands upon
god are even greater upon the sabbath
than upon other days
his people then
leave their usual employment
and spend the time in meditation and
worship they ask more favors of him on
the sabbath than on other days they
demand more of his attention which i
thought was interesting
that we do put increased demands on god
on sabbath everybody's in church praying
on sabbath you know
um
but um
she she says that um we need to spend
time in meditation
that meditation is good
so meditating the right way is fine the
problem is meditating the wrong way
most meditation or much of
modern day meditation
is based on the premise
that
you can find the answers to your life
within
that you have within you the answers to
your life
you just have to go in there and find
them out
but the bible tells me that it is not
within man to direct his own steps so
the bible is saying just the opposite
right that the secret to running your
life is not within
so it is how you meditate
and what you meditate on
meditating is good if your meditation is
out focused
looking for
seeking for
focusing on jesus and not on yourself
the the fact the fact of the matter is
that there are ways that seem right unto
a man but they are the ways of
destruction so if you're getting all of
your answers for life from drawing on
your own resources one you're going to
run out of gas very quickly yes and two
many of the answers you will get while
you are running are going to be wrong
so meditation is good but seeking to get
the answers only through
self-examination is incorrect and will
lead you astray well said well i think
that that was a very important
distinction that you have just made
because it is important to know the
difference between biblical meditation
and false meditation and to put it
simply
as see i said it
biblical meditation is god's center
and false meditation is self-centered
we should not con confuse
biblical meditation with eastern
meditation that centers himself or yes
emptying up of the mind
so that we can
get to the essence of ourselves
very
practical points on how to do or how to
perform christian uh meditation well
meditation the word in and of itself is
not bad and you just read it from the
spirit of prophecy elinora uses it she
uses the word meditation in the bible we
find some illusions to meditation verse
10 of psalm 46 we find a command
be still
and know that i am god
i will be exalted among the hidden i
will be exalted in the earth so god
calls us to be
to be still
and know that he's god
we find in genesis 24 63
how
the hebrews or god's people perform
meditation so we see here isaac when he
was waiting
the arrival of his future wife
we read here in genesis 24
verse
and isaac went out
to meditate
in the field at the even tide and he
lifted up his eyes and so and behold the
camels were coming so there is an aspect
of biblical meditation
which um has to do with being out in
nature
not because we want to find the answers
from
nature
but because we can behold god's creation
and character nature nature is not god
but nature to nation we can
learn
more about god
in psalm 1 verse 2
tells us that the righteous man
meditates
in the law of god day and night so this
is not a meditation that has to do with
emptying out our minds
but
we're actually filling up our minds with
the law of god with the word
of god
psalm 63 verse 6
even says that while we are on bed
we can think of god and his promises yes
that is uh some that is also meditation
um
we cannot meditation is not always
reading the bible per se
you can think of him you can think of
his promises in your mind psalm 63 verse
6 says
when i remember thee upon my bed and
meditate on thee in the night watches
sometimes when we can't sleep
we
pray or we think of god or we speak to
him in our minds and through prayer
psalm 5 1-3 we see here david meditating
through prayer
that is also part of of christian
meditation david here says give ear to
my words o lord consider my meditation
yes harking unto the voice of my cry my
king and my god unto thee will i pray my
voice shall die here in the morning so
he's praying and he says hearken unto
my meditation one more thing real quick
i love this quote from this hour of ages
page 83
it would be well one of my favorite
quotes yes it would be well for us to
spend a thoughtful hour
each day in contemplation or in
meditation
of the life of christ we should take it
point by point and let the imagination
grasp each scene especially the closing
ones as we that's dwell upon his great
sacrifice for us our confidence in him
will be more constant our love will be
quickened and we shall be more deeply
imbued with his spirit amen amen amen
well done and well said i've got just
one other sure spirit of prophecy quote
on to add from desire of age page 362.
there is a tendency
illinois says to pray less
and to have less faith
like the disciples
we are in danger of losing sight of our
dependence on god
and seeking to make a savior of our
activity
we need to look constantly to jesus
realizing that it is his power
which does the work
while we are to labor earnestly for the
salvation of the laws
we must also take time for meditation
and prayer and for the study of the word
of god
only the work accomplished with much
prayer and sanctified by the merit of
christ will in the end prove
to have been efficient for good amen so
meditation and prayer study of the word
of god are important to your success in
your labors for the lord but also to the
spiritual growth uh in your own personal
life
you need time you've got to turn off the
tv you've got to turn off the
background noise and that's why going
out into nature is so effective because
you don't have the computer you don't
have the cell phone you don't have all
of these other things crowding in
because you need peace and quiet for
meditation and a lot of us sadly pastor
are not really comfortable with too much
peace and quiet
i know people who have the the
television on or the radio one all day
from morning to night because they just
don't like quiet right they want
something going on in a house all of the
time um
and i guess if if you have secrets
unsealed or through abn or one of the
that's fine but really you need to shut
off that noise every now and again and
just focus in on god and meditate on him
uh the closing scenes of christ ministry
ellen white says things of that nature
you will find peace and you will find
strength for when you are tested and
assaulted by the enemy so good question
well done so the remaining of time that
we have let's try to answer this
question is a very good question also
from john triplett
and his question is in regards to the
law of god
uh he understands that the law of god
existed before man's creation and that
it is eternal in nature
he quotes then a review on harold april
22 1902 the moral law was never a type
of a shadow it existed before man's
creation and will endure as long as
god's throne remains it is unchangeable
and unalterable infinite and eternal but
then comes the fourth commandment that
is connected with the creation of the
world
and jesus himself said that sabbath was
made for men so his question is how can
if the sabbath commandment was just
created or was
said at the creation
story
how is it then the law is eternal if we
have a commandment that had an origin
when god created man
that's a good question it it seems much
more difficult than it is
there are two ways to
attack this while i'm going to isaiah
58.
um
one the the commandments are a
transcript of the character of god amen
they
be speak who and what god is all about
so they are as eternal
as god is eternal uh when you were born
there were certain things in your dna
that presuppose what you will like what
you don't like how you will approach
life those things are all pre-wired in
your dna
when
so the commandments are as old as god is
he is without beginning so he's always
had a way of doing things when he
codified
the way he is
they became the ten commandments
but they also they always existed
because god always exists exactly now
the the sabbath is just a designated
time
to worship him
that will continue throughout all
eternity
uh angels have always and constantly
worship god
but he segmented
a specific period of time for man to do
so so that we would have a formalized
relationship with him a formalized time
to meet him amen i like what you said
codify
the principles of the law of god are
eternal
and god
had to when he gives us the ten
commandments he adopts them
alan white uses this word adaptation ten
commandments are brief ten brief
adaptations of the great principle of
the law of god which is love
to our humanity
and
we we should not limit the law of god to
10 commandments even the entire
revelation
is also an extension of the law of god
the torah
that is an extension of the law of god
and and god had to be very specific in
certain things
because
because of sin we didn't understand but
the principle behind the seventh
commandment is worship and that
commandment is in the entire universe
yes worship our creator but to us as
human beings
god gave us the sabbath
so that we may not forget
that he is our creator any final
comments
um i'm looking at the clock um
and i i want to refer our our uh
questionnaire to isaiah 66 23 and 24. uh
the sabbath will always be god will
always have a time for formal worship
amen a time when we will formally meet
with him but
god is as near as your prayer you can
always meet with him you can always uh
be near him um and we better cut it off
there before we run out of time
thank you very much for being with us
and god bless you
[Music]
you